everyone so this morning we finally got
a new batch of results released
uh the election results that is they do
not only impact the presidential race
of course several local races are still
close and they are still in the balance
as ballots are counted so let's look at
some of those races we're going to start
with congressional district 3 incumbent
susie lee trying to hold off republican
dan rodimer there you see that susie lee
has a slight lead right now
in district 4 these are new numbers
again democrat stephen horsford looks to
be a bit closer to keeping his seat
against republican jim marchant with 50
percent of the vote right now
in the clark county commission race the
closest race of the mall right now is
for district c
current las vegas city councilman
stavros anthony against former secretary
of state ross miller you can see the
neck and neck although mr anthony has
taken a bit of a lead
all right now let's take a look at the
race for clark county school trustees
with district a lisa guzman appears to
be over liberty leavitt
in district b katie williams still
exploits to be jeff
prophet and evelyn garcia morales leads
tamika henry in district c
it appears school board president lola
brooks is also keeping her seat
she leads teacher alexis salt in
district e we will have more election
coverage coming up here in just a few
minutes